bien emmanuel macron l'a martelé la
priorité absolue c'est d'assurer la
sécurité des ressortissants français
bloqués à kaboul ainsi que tous les
afghans qui ont travaillé toutes ces
années aux côtés des français emmanuel
macron le sel cette situation aura des
conséquences géopolitiques dramatique
pour elle la région est les propos du
président de la république concernant
les flux migratoires par exemple ont
provoqué un tollé parmi elles à gauche
il estime que ce n'était pas le moment
approprié pour aborder ce genre de sujet
s'il a promis de protéger les afghans et
les afghanes et des talibans il a été
néanmoins très clair il faut se protéger
et des flux migratoires écoutez le nous
devons anticiper et nous protéger contre
des flux migratoires irréguliers
important qui mettrait en danger ceux
qui les empruntent et nourrir et les
trafics de toute nature nous porterons
donc en lien avec la république fédérale
d'allemagne je me suis entretenu il ya
quelques instants à ce sujet avec la
chancelière merkel et avec d'autres
états européens
une initiative pour construire sans
attendre une réponse robuste coordonnée
et unie qui passera par la lutte contre
les flux irréguliers la solidarité dans
l'effort l'harmonisation des critères de
protection et la mise en place de
coopérations avec les pays de transit et
d'accueil après l'allocution d'emmanuel
macron joe biden est enfin sorti du
silence lui qui a été sévèrement
critiquée par l'opposition également à
l'international il a fermement défendu
le retrait des troupes si dans le pays
après à 20 ans de présence joe biden
déclare que le but ultime est des états
unis n'était pas de réformer l
afghanistan écoutez le
notre mission en afghanistan n'a jamais
été de construire une nation elle n'a
jamais été de créer une démocratie
unifiée centralisée notre seul intérêt
national vital en afghanistan reste
aujourd'hui et a toujours été d'empêcher
une attaque terroriste sur le sol
américain
un locataire de la maison blanche a
menacé les talibans de représailles
s'ils troubles les évacuations qui sont
actuellement en cours selon by donne
l'armée afghane est responsable de ce
chaos des propos qui laissent un goût
amer aux afghans et afghanes est livré
aux mains des talibans